Captain's Log we find ourselves in the
Aegean Sea near Greece's 4-9 archipelago
an underwater archaeologists dream come
true I imagine a predecessors ancient
seafarers with an unparalleled and
profound sense of adventure you're doing
it again love oh sorry we're here about
12 miles from the coast of Greece where
a group of scientists uncovered 22
different shipwrecks late last year all
in an area of only 17 square miles
that's smaller than the island of
Manhattan
speaking of Manhattan's next time Brian
easy on the bitters
some of these ships date back over 2500
years and while most of the vessels are
unrecognizable
after 25 centuries of oceanic decay
these underwater archaeologists found
some pretty incredible artifacts thank
you
much better on the bidders Brian now
what do you think should we call Peter
Peter how goes it
find any ancient artifacts yet today we
actually came across another 23
shipwrecks in the 40 archipelago July
2016 no ship hardly 45 ships in fact
over the course of these explorations we
found pots and ceramics that haven't
been found on shipwrecks before
these islands were an important
avocation channel the large volume of
ship traffic in every time period and
these ships were they fully loaded yes
you could say that
thanks very much Peter you are the man
no time to waste there must be more
priceless trip antiquities around here
somewhere Oh Sadat's engaged
you